i should have never hung out with you
last time i had a massive episode after
you left
are you serious you're not good for
people dad you know what we started
talking about it yeah i'll tell you what
i'll tell you exactly what happened tell
me we started talking about it and as we
talked about it i said my brain was
going bert
you're being too loosey-goosey with this
you got to respect it
you're talking about you're having fun
with it something's going to show up and
then we took that phone call do you
remember we took that phone call on my
ipad yeah i do my and i had returned his
call and in returning his call i
realized i sent him my new number
remember i had to get rid of my number
because i got doxxed right so now i just
sent out my jeremy you'll send me a clip
that clips so jeremy could show what
we're talking about this is i was on
bert's podcast and so it's connect just
shut up well let's answer it no you
don't want to answer it why and i'll go
this is howie mandel how the [ __ ] did
you get my number how the [ __ ] did you
get my let me answer them did you just
call me
uh i'm not sure it's howie mandel you
just
hung up
no there's no way that that's how it
meant yeah it is you just dialed me and
i dialed back you hung up the phone
what do you want dude it's howie mandel
burke [ __ ] chrysler out of nowhere a
fan in the middle of your podcast a fan
your home phone
rang yeah my face time because i
facetime everybody and so my face time
started ringing on my thing
my number had gotten given out and and i
had to get a new number and it was
really kind of overwhelming and i was
and i got very strict with like who got
my number right i was like i got a new
number no one's getting it so that guy
calls i called back and then calling
back
i called back from my computer but it
gave him my new number he thought it was
your number then he sees you and goes no
[ __ ] way that's who he called he
called you yeah yeah why are you no
[ __ ] way
my number got leaked on reddit and that
happens
i had to get a new phone number it
happens all day every day what i what it
has happened is is tethered to my
computer that old phone and this phone
are tethered to my computer so the face
times come up i was just in a i was just
in a meeting i was in a producer's
meeting and it just it just happened
non-stop and i'm on zoom and i'm like
click click click he was like is this
howie's number or bert's number he had
already had my old number right and i
went i was goddamn i gave him my my new
number so i texted him hey man this is
my new number please don't give it to
anyone wait but it wasn't anybody that
you knew
i know i know and i tell you you said it
you just
go here's my new number to a family i
don't know i started spiraling and then
i and howie and when i did it i texted
another person i texted another fan and
i sent out my number and then within the
second of three minutes i sent my new
number to like 15 different people and i
but you told them don't share it don't
share it
and and man i
it was it was it was the beginning of a
little downward spiral that everything
and then and then i i hadn't even looked
at those messages that had come in right
so i replied to one one person about
something negative and then i realized i
replied to the wrong person and i was
all over the map and then i just stopped
and i was like god damn it howie what
did you do to me what did i do what did
you do because because
i said if i never touched that computer
that's what i was my rule but that guy
called and then we were like we were
like all right let's call him back and
so i was like oh exactly come on we'll
call him back and then as soon as i
touch that computer all the negativity
that i had disappeared just showed right
back up and i was like god damn it so
yeah are you afraid to talk to me today
no no i actually laid in bed today and i
was like i was like hey that was a fluke
won't happen again it won't happen again
you want to prank call someone right now
no no no
so let me ask you i told him i told your
dad i was like i never i'm not a big
prank caller turns out i'm a huge prank
caller
i love prank calls you have a new number
now yeah 3-1-0
[Laughter]
[Music]
you